thank you so much for having me i'm
really excited to be here
um i hope i will do uh justice as the
final speaker of your seminar series
um so yeah as michael said i just joined
the hci at cmu
and i called my lab the interactive
structures lab which uh hopefully we'll
see soon why um so um
just to uh you know briefly about my
background i did my phd with patrick
bardisch in uh berlin and then i moved
on to eth
zurich where i did my uh postdoc with
all the soaking warnings
in a computer graphics lab so that was
really interesting
um so in my work i use
additional fabrications for 3d printers
mainly and
to create and the goal is to create
interactive structures
now i thought about what does
interactive structures mean what do
these
you know what what what what are the
characteristics of these things
and i kind of came up with this that
interactive structures
my definition are structures that embed
functionality
such that they can react to simple input
with complex behavior
and so this is this is kind of like the
theme of uh you know why we're doing
these materials we want to
embed functionality into materials that
are ideally even passive
so what can these types of structures do
well they can
embody robotic movement for example
they can embed very simple computation
to kind of verify inputs to their system
in terms of logic
they can also communicate back to the
user
and lately we were also looking at oh
this is wrong it's card 21.
we were also looking at how to make
these types of very adaptable structures
from materials that can be used at home
so we can broaden participation and
they're really mass producible
now taking all of these um things
together that all these properties that
can embed into
structures um we really think of kind of
that materials can be entire devices so
that's kind of the
the vision if it's a will so material
structures that can receive input
process that input in order to produce
output
okay so this was kind of like a brief um
overview and preview of what you will
see in the rest of the talk but i want
to
kind of take a step back and you know
kind of like
also show you introduce this topic a
little bit more broadly
where it comes from now if you think
about
materials because that is really the
theme of this um of this talk
we have kind of like a set of materials
that are mostly sourced from nature
and they have like some particular um
properties
that come from the natural occurrence
now if you want to do something more
complex with those materials then
well you can start um you know layering
things together
creating composite materials as you see
in this helmet example
right you have like rigid materials with
some
softer padding now if you look very very
closely at this foam
material that is glued into this helmet
then
you would see that there are like a lot
of many like many many many different
sorry many um randomly oriented beams
now the idea of engineering materials is
actually that you don't
have randomly oriented beams but they
take those beams
and you could orient them in a way to
achieve some function
so so here um some people already did
that in terms of helmets
where they created like this lattice
structure that can uh
really um you know damp forces in a
highly specific manner
and so this is really the you know core
of uh what uh what uh type of design
space we actually
um see or being opened up from
engineering and giving us
uh you know many challenges and
opportunities in terms of designing
systems for them
so we can engineer materials
here's another example of why we would
want to do that
so i hope you see this video okay
so you're supposed to see two
eggs that fall down and the right one
is breaking and the left one is not so
that is because
the structure is engineered in a way to
absorb
that force so there are those dynamic
loads
so i hope this video play i don't know
sometimes this video doesn't seem to
play very okay but
what you see is like people uh like
hands just like pushing down these cells
and it kind of like gets
stuck in each other so um this is really
designed to have
two table stable states and like every
time
um it transitions into this second state
where it kind of like deforms and stays
within the structure there's some energy
trapping going on and that energy
is the energy that is not giving back to
the egg so this is how
this structure for example works
um another example that i also always
like to show
is this one it is a very
simple looking material
and as you compress it downwards um
traditional materials conventional
materials would actually expand in the
orthogonal direction in this case the
horizontal direction this one clearly
does not it does the opposite and it
does contract
now this is again a very highly unusual
property um it's called an exotic
material but you can
think of it as like a volume changing
material so you have a simple input that
is a one-dimensional
compression leading to a two
like to a two-dimensional um shrinking
of the material
um so that means that you have you know
you can use simple
um actuation techniques uh and you know
save on
on motors and whatever you need to
incorporate otherwise and control and so
on so that is kind of like what you can
offload into the material now the reason
why this
material works this way is just its
decomposition into cells
and this and these cells are very simple
they're just
circular cutouts so it doesn't even look
very special
but the whole concept that i would try
to convey is that you can
design these cells in more complex
shapes in order to
um uh influence the overall or like to
determine the overall macroscopic
behavior of that material
so this can be useful for example in
fact it was um
uh designed for the uh
for you know solar panel expansion and
this is exactly this example where
you want to have lightweight actuations
for simple actuation one-dimensional
but then you want to have like a big uh
surface opening up
so the miura ori pattern which is also
an
exotic property but it's based on
origami and folding
that is that was invented for this use
case
so it all boils down to geometry
so these things that i was showing you
here without naming them explicitly
were mechanical meta materials that's
what they're
uh called and these are artificial
structures so really engineered
designed architected structures that
have unusual properties that originate
in their geometry rather than in the
specific material that they're
made of so that means that we can design
the geometry
um to you know create a material that
does something
interesting um and and that geometry far
exceeds the influence of
uh you know the material behavior rather
than the than the actual
base material that um you know the
geometry has been made off
so in traditionally uh meta materials
have been understood
as materials i mean it's right there in
the world
but um we take a slightly different
perspective and really think of them
more as devices
so if you have functionality the
functionality doesn't have to be
you know uniform over the whole um
over the whole material it doesn't have
to be a material property
it can be something useful so
this different perspective led us to um
investigate a number of these
kind of elements that i'm showing here
starting with like you know analog
processing and in the sense that you
know you have some
input coming in and then you want some
output out and in an analog sense
well that can be uh mechanisms
so here you see a um
a door latch that consists of only one
part
and really the um you know the
functionality is inscribed in its uh
geometry which is very aperiodic in this
sense
so the way that this works is that the
user is pushing down the handle
that creates a rotation around this axis
that causes these cells to shear and
they in turn
uh cause the ledge to move inwards
now what combines so essentially we
build on the
overall concept of metal materials but
we weren't less
we were less strict about it so for
example um well we did divide this into
cells
but um we had different uh types of
cells so
a rigid cell that essentially just
contains a um
a diagonal creates triangles so has no
movement um and then by just leaving out
that diagonal
we create shearing cells that allow for
a controlled directional
movement
now just to compare this briefly to a
regular
like traditional door latch that you
might have seen that
the only point i want to make here is
that it contains
many parts and this is a very simple
door latch um
in this case it's six parts including
two springs which are really hard
to assemble now
this uh door lash that we created
obviously
consists of only one part now
it consists of since it consists only of
one part there's no assembly necessary
which is great because that means that
um you know novice users can also create
this geometry and send it off to the
printer and take it take it out and have
no assembly necessary
but the other part which i find even
more interesting is that because it
you know doesn't require any assembly it
can be integrated um as a larger
into larger structures so you could you
can imagine
printing the entire door with the door
latch mechanism
and even with the door lock as i will
show you later in one piece
and that is um you know since the
functionality is
only defined by its geometry that also
means that it gives us
the opportunity to create um you know
software systems to
enable users novice users uh to also
participate
in um you know designing mechanisms
designing you know like being part of
problem solving for their own little
mechanical
um problems at home for example
so we created this um editor that runs
in the browser
um it's based on um so it's coded in
javascript
and it has a finite element analysis in
in the background and so you can really
have this really tight design loop by
just
you know using this as a voxel editor
essentially
and uh and then testing your uh you know
the behavior of your mechanism
uh using the integrated fda
this also works in uh 3d um in the
editor
and a couple of other applications that
we also wanted to
showcase or you know investigate first
is um
pliers for example again consist of one
part
and they are strong enough to tighten
screws or
lift things or or such
tasks now the other example that
um is my personal favorite example
because it's
so you know not super evident what it
does
is this one so it looks like a strip of
material well which it is
but what you what it also has it
it holds two pencils and so as the user
is drawing
well it recreates that drawing so
essentially it's like a strip of
material but it has this integrated
function of
you know being a copy machine if you so
will in a very simplified case of course
um yeah and then this one you already
saw
in the in the little preview so we also
looked at if we can you know potentially
integrate robotic movement
into these type of of materials um
such that you can you know in the end
also be more
complex have robots that are very robust
um and small because they also
miniaturize well
since there is no assembly necessary
okay so now that i've seen like a couple
of these examples
um also now that you know after we
investigated like
uh the applications were you know where
such materials could be relevant
why would why would we want to do that
um
the real question like the next question
if you look into it a little bit deeper
is
well what type of transformations are
you know can these materials enable
and and how do we get there so
transformations is
well mechanism is essentially that's the
only
you know being of uh you know
transforming as
a set of input forces and movements into
a set of uh
output forces and movements so if we
just look at kind of like the
motion paths so we're looking at the
movement the green input movement
and we want to transform that into the
purple output movement
then it turns out that most of these
applications that i just showed you
earlier
they were really just rigid
transformations so
that was not in terms of transformations
not really
exciting but the question is like can we
do more
and now the thing the reason why these
were
ending up just being rigid
transformations is that that they were
essentially
um you know hand designed
and although these elements of these you
know
only have shearing cells that deform and
then
the rigid cells that um kind of
propagate
alexandra can can you say a little bit
what a
rigid transformation is or is not and
what the implications of that is for
those of us without the background
sure yeah um well essentially it's so
the input
the green input path is just rotated
scaled or um and and or uh
translated well okay that's strictly f
fine transformations
um you know that that's the only
transformation that happens but it's
nothing
non-linear for example like there's no
stretching there's no
smoothing there's no you know just
it's not really changing the path
significantly it's just
placing it somewhere else and making
thanks
thank you
all right so um
it turns out that even though these um
these cells are just like
you know shearing and then you know not
shearing
um it's still somewhat uh it's actually
pretty uh difficult to design these
meta materials well so essentially the
next step
uh is then to compute uh those
you know cell assignments that achieve a
certain transformation so here for
example
we created this little editor where
users
put this rotary input and then draw
hand draw a walking like a walk cycle
type
path and then our system kind of you
know
in an inverse design approach uh finds
the
cells at the distribution and the
placement
um that would um create this type of uh
transformation
so essentially what we do here is that
we take kind of like the path
that the uh the cell grid that the users
just drew
um and their paths um and we set all of
the
cells to be shearing so we have kind of
the maximum degrees of freedom in the
beginning
and then we want to find first anchors
so somewhere where it's bolted to the
ground because otherwise it would just
fly around and we just do that um
analytically
and then we want to find as i mentioned
these uh kind of like why do we place
these rigid cells such that uh you know
these two paths
um kind of morph into each other so we
have this
you know transformation going on um
yeah so we really want to minimize the
distance between the user input path
which is the gray path and then the
cell principle so that's the path that
it's the result
of when we actuate any given um
you know of these cell assignments
um the point that i want to make with
this one here
is that it's a really big design space
because we're in uh
because we're in a discrete uh search
space
we need some sort of combinatorial
optimization
and essentially we have like two to the
power what two because we have two
states to the power of
uh cell number of cells configurations
and we cannot really use um you know
gradient based
methods or something like that to kind
of like traverse like find a local
minimum
um faster so we're kind of ending up in
like
you know well combinatorial optimization
some something more stochastic
which means we need to find out
if we you know which parts of the search
base do we even have to look at so which
configurations are meaningful what are
meaningful in quotes here because
in our case that means um well
do we have do we have to look through
the whole design space
um well in the que and the answer is no
so here you see
seven different cell arrangements that
are all
doing the same thing like if you look at
the paths that they produce they all do
the same thing
so um for us it's the same mechanism
because that's what we're looking for
right um so they're not distinct and
therefore we know that we
don't have to search the the entire
space
great so um essentially we
model the structural constraints um i
will not go into
the details of how we do that but um
essentially we just build up uh
we model their constraints in a
constraint graph and that allows us
uh to significantly uh reduce the search
space
from this um kind of quadratically
growing
gray search space into this linearly
blue search space
so what this enables us is uh or
essentially what what we learned from
from this is that
well well these metal materials are
really interesting because the reason
why as i mentioned in the beginning um
you can design these materials that have
um
you know non like unusual properties
is because they work together in concert
to create this sort of
uh um you know material properties
in the kind of traditional metamaterial
sense or these mechanisms that
we looked at now
that means that they are discrete still
and
as i just mentioned large search space
uh
combinatorial optimization not fun
now the next questions is how can we
compute this more efficiently
use some continuous optimization and and
you know round to those um discrete
states something like that because what
that would lead
us to do is to create a more
principled characterization of which
cell types
together do something um interesting
so the point i want to make is that
metal materials are very young and not
very well understood it's not clear
um what are the limits what types of
functions can we
bring into geometry what functionality
can we offload into the material
and whatnot um and
uh yeah i think that
especially in hci um we are
probably the most best equipped to um
create systems that allow people to
explore
and at the same time optimize like nit
gritty things for them
but give them more opportunities to
just explore the the you know the design
space
better because for example what was not
clear is that it can have like these
self-intersecting
transformations which is really
interesting um you know you have like a
rotary input and then you get this eight
out um as in the
left example that was just not clear at
all
if that could do that it can have
oscillating thing uh
emotions which means it's highly uh
non-linear motions
or smoothing out these corners so that's
really what i mean with like you know
these rigid transformations is somewhat
obvious um and you know somewhat easy to
make with
traditional materials like traditional
you know mechanisms as well
um and and these ones are really
interesting that you can even create
them
in such a small packaging and
miniaturize them very well
okay so um
one thing since these were all
mechanisms there are analog machines so
that means that you know you have if you
have some
input force into an analog system um
at each step of these um
of this system which in this case is
kind of like the cells
deforming and kind of like deforming its
neighbor deforming its neighbor and so
on
um there's some decay happening at each
and every one of these steps
meaning that the output will always be
smaller than the input so the
um the latch moves in less inwards than
the
user pushes down the handle which is
very
you know normal for analog systems
essentially you can think of it as noise
um now there are some things that you
can do
so for example um actually let me just
skip up over this um and just say like
we can essentially
use better technology to reduce that
noise level essentially
so we can use higher resolution printers
or like you know mix soft and rigid
materials
and then we get a better stiffness ratio
which means that we can make more
complex machines
but even though we can mitigate this
noise
uh level in these you know mechanical
structures
um we can never get rid of it like if we
stay in an analog
regime we will always have some sort of
noise and signal decay
so how to get to really get rid of that
we go digital
so we looked at this um and created like
a
different type of cell um so this cell
holds a bi-stable spring so by stable
spring is kind of like if you pinch your
credit card between your fingers
and then you push it over it stays in
that buckle direction if you push it
back it stays in that direction so it
has
two states um and in this case it looks
like this
so at the tenth state the relaxed state
that is printed in
and so if you um chain many of these
cells
um you push the
left one that kind of snaps through
and pushes the next cell and that snaps
through
and that pushes the next cell and so on
now the point is that they all have some
energy stored
in this deformation and so every time
they
trigger each other um they release that
energy
which means that we're not um we don't
have
signal decay anymore because we're not
dependent on the
very like on the input forces at the
very
beginning of this chain reaction
essentially so essentially it's kind of
like a rounding you know
um which is what we think of
like as our adaptation of um uh you know
mechanical computation
and that means that you can chain you
know as many
of these cells as you want and the
output can be arbitrarily far away
meaning that you can do
more complex machines
so here is the signal transmission
in action and you even see how
we go around the corner there a little
bit and so
um we use this in an example of the
of a door lock where the user inputs the
code and
only if that code is correct which is
evaluated in these cells
um the signal travels all the way up the
bolts are retracted
and the door can be opened so here you
see kind of what i was
alluding to that you have like this the
door lock and the door latch
and um that is all mechanical can be
integrated into the whole
door um and and
you know just make up for more uh
kind of embedding functionality into
materials
um so we also looked at gates we do
model the nand gate
um and so the current scope of this
project
is really that it can do um
combinational logic
um and um you know it's time independent
so it's really a combinational circuit
now obviously it's not a sequential
circuit yet so um
so what we would want to do is first of
all we somehow need to reset
our springs into the first position and
then
that would enable us to um you know add
a clock signal
do more computation rounds and then
maybe
you know also have like some protected
areas that can act as memory and so on
now while we were talking
about computation it's not really
the point of this project is um actually
not to
you know like reinvent computers um
but uh what you have in these
cells is that you have essentially every
step you can have an actuator
so you can have something that kind of
pokes out into the other material as it
did now with the bolts and blocking the
door
you can have that essentially in every
in every single cell so that means these
are really effectively
um can be a layer to other
metal materials such that you can
reconfigure
the metal materials with many many
actuators if you so will so
having like really thousands of
actuators throughout the entire material
which would be otherwise challenging
with like you know motors or
um uh you know other types of
actuators so
the vision here would be really to um
you know kind of like react
to um you know have sensor cells
essentially that
can react uh can trigger these types of
reconfigurations you know and
and apply that logic that's embedded in
those cells
uh to reconfigure um you know the
material itself
so i want to mention just very briefly
how we also use these
materials to compute to
communicate with the user so we did that
by
using textures um so here you see this
door handle can be set to three
different textures so they kind of
additively
um combine as you compress it and they
can mean
well you know i'm available or i'm not
kind of busy or pleased to not enter
so here um we show how this is actually
that's it's a global compression force
that lets users transition through these
pre-coded
textures and import most importantly
they are they have a defined sequence so
here it was
designed that first of these ripley
cells come out
and then secondly only as the user keeps
compressing the spiky cells come out
oh sorry
so essentially what this um illustrates
is um kind of
giving users um more um
like
um you know you you can uh adapt your um
objects in c2 as the weather changes you
might want to uh change the grip
uh on your shoe so it's very easy to
actuate as well because it's only this
global actuation so that was
also focus of this project
okay so lastly what i want to um briefly
show
is that um while we were looking really
at the functionality that we can embed
into these
objects the question is also well we
need to fabricate that somehow
and so far we were always using 3d
printing
now certainly branding is really slow
and i also don't see that
getting faster anytime soon well laser
cutting for
uh you know on the contrary is very fast
now typically these metal materials um
you know do consist of
complex shapes this is why they're
mostly
3d printed but i think that also really
heavily
inhibits their ability to have like some
real world
impact soon enough and so we were really
looking at
um you know creating metal materials
that are explicitly
fabrication aware in this case laser
cutting
and so we cut we came up with these
ruffled shapes essentially so here
here's how they work we they work almost
with any
sheet material we prototype most of them
um with paper
obviously paper is not very stable now
if you uh
ruffle them up and this is the same
paper same length um
it can resist forces so it increases the
stiffness quite a bit
now obviously the size of these ruffles
can also be
um uh can be designed so the denser they
are the stiffer the rough
uh the material becomes and so the loose
loose ruffles great brother
um uh you know soft materials
and the highly localizable you could
even do that in
3d by adding conical twists and so on
so
they're quick to um fabricate
um it's also easy to assemble actually
and
um by having these like interlocking
tabs there and they're numbered and
everything
we don't even need like any external
fasteners or something like that
so we created again a computational
design tool to solve where these
connections should uh happen that's also
not super obvious
um and in this case it's really a shape
of approximation
so we want to um take that initial
ruffle up there at the head and like
pull it out
until it um you know fills the the
the um cross section of the teddy's head
and then we extrude just in the in the
third dimension so we create this
um two and a half d volumetric
ruffles essentially
and obviously we can do that for the
rest of the teddy
to create something like this
now while you know creating your own
type of teddy bears
um and such i think could be really fun
you know you can do that with your kids
and learn some engineering skills at the
same time and
explore materials and stuff like that um
the next thing that we're actually
looking at
in these using these structures
is looking at creating prosthetics that
are again
highly customizable but yet they can be
manufactured in a very cheap way by just
cutting
sheet materials very likely not paper
but rather sheet metal and then ship it
to
to the user so i'm very excited about
uh this uh next uh project we're really
focusing on
on ankles uh for now um but i think that
this can really have some
impact and you know reach uh have like
you know they're very lightweight and
rich underserved communities as well
well obviously there's much more there's
not only
um laser cutting as kind of like faster
and more efficient
fabrication methods but you can also
think of molding stamping
thermoforming and so on all of these are
way faster to make
than 3d printing but also come with
their own constraints
which we can optimize for or you know
can develop systems for
so in conclusion um my
i find metal materials very fascinating
which is why we started looking into
those it wasn't clear what
we specifically could uh do with them
but we really
kind of like ended up at this angle of
you know
not not seeing them as materials but
really thinking of
them as devices seem like how far can we
push
uh the functionality that we can
integrate into
uh into materials and this is just you
know
we're walking towards that um uh
goal now the big why we would even want
to do that
is they have a couple of general
benefits which they're
um very lightweight um just by
definition they're
porous and mostly therefore lightweight
um you can
embed a complex behavior by using just
one material
something that typically you know often
there are like composites and other
types of materials involved that are you
know very hard to
dispose of so therefore you can think of
metal materials
being more sustainable if you use only
one material
the miniaturized really well because
there's no assembly um
involved so you can use um you know some
nano uh lithography or some uh
like uh fabrication techniques uh like
that
and even think about um you know having
like a
complex stance like this
cylindrical one that's an easy example
um but you can
uh you can even think about something
that deploys uh
in more complex uh
uh you know blood vessels
shapes um and also their lifetime
is um more like definable
not necessarily longer but easier to
foresee because
um dirt or something like that does not
uh get caught up
because the only one uh one monolithic
structure
so um to really get to this
kind of like materials that can
incorporate more
functionality um i think we definitely
won't need um
you know lots of hci like there's many
uh
in in computer graphics engineering um
there have been quite some works in hci
it's starting to
uh happen and we also need a lot of
design and creativity from people to
really explore
you know how how intelligent can we make
our
future systems to reduce the load on
um you know actuators and system
complexity
um i just want to point out um
that you know design tools inform novel
structures novel structures inform
design tools this is how we work
and there's like a lot of exciting
application areas prosthetics that i
mentioned medical implants exoskeletons
or soft robotics and so forth
so um this is what we work on in the lab
and we will push further in the future
if you're interested in that i'm looking
for postdocs right now
and so feel free to reach out to me
and i'm happy to take questions
thank you so much alex we
have a few questions i will
um i will i will kick one off with a
question
say if the final design consists of one
piece what is repairing look like does
it require a full replacement can you
fix a single part of the device
of the device yeah that's a good
question
um so one part of the answer
uh can be that you can really compute
how long the lifetime will be and
optimize for that so optimize the
structures for that
given that you know the the
environmental influences like you know
uv or whatnot
um so so that's one part and if it then
uh really
breaks for real i mean you can also
think about
um having uh you know structures that
can
make this um replaceable so where you
can take
the the door ledge out of the door and
then put like a new one
uh and if you if you want it this is
just one example
but you can you can yeah i think i think
it's absolutely a great uh
thought to design for the entire
lifetime of the entire object and not
just of the material itself yeah
um i should just say quote these are the
hands down the coolest mechanisms i've
ever seen since jansen's strand beasts
how do you think about the durability of
these structures given that they deform
are they meant for use at scale or more
for discovery and mentioning and
understanding
invention and understanding
um kind of both but i think
um i think you can uh
know that already meant for for use as
well
so um i will i will say that we did not
have like a production ready um
you know optimization and and and like
in our case we were really looking at
the design of the structures
um but there are things like um for
example you
can add additional constraints into your
optimization that
given the material properties that you
use to make that
mechanism from uh like in our case it
was a thermoplastic urethane
um given that you know the
the um the properties of that material
you can
optimize the structure such that when
they bend they don't
ever over bend such that they exit the
linear elastic regime which means that
in that regime they always return to
their um
um original shape now there are things
like
fatigue and things like that and there's
like you know like
does it break after i don't know 2
million
cycles or how fast those cycles have to
be to break
um that is something that we did not um
investigate very thoroughly but we did
hook up the
jansen walker actually our meta material
version of the jansen walker
and to a power drill and let it uh
run for well it okay
it ran for an hour and then the metal
axle broke
um and there was like 5 000
at five thousand rpm so um
the material didn't really have any tear
at all um
and but but as i said like we would have
to do like you know real
um you know kind of engineering style um
measurements on that which we didn't do
but from what i've seen and from what my
experiences are with these
materials a you can design for longevity
and we can definitely
measure those and engineer that
ask um about if there's um potential
application
in tracks um both as someone with shin
splints but also
someone who loves horses and horse
racing a lot of horses break their legs
on hard materials and i'm wondering if
that sort of combination of give but
strength
but poor bil uh ability to let water
pass through it if there's some
if there's any exploration on uh using
it in that way
um i might not be very familiar with
that area
so um what
sort of what type of splits for horses
um both horse races and actually other
kinds of athletes
um often damage their legs in the
horse's case it's fatal
because they'll break their legs um just
because the surface is too hard
and what i'm seeing here is an
incredibly strong
surface potentially that would have give
and would let water pass through it
and there seems like a lot of wonderful
applications there but
just wondered if that was an interesting
place to take it i always love to hear
about new application areas that i
you know just like never got in touch
with so that sounds super interesting
um i mean i i
the thing with the prosthetics came up
because i met someone
um randomly who works in that area and
it's like hey you could you know
could we use that and i was like i never
thought about it awesome yeah
so um maybe we should talk more i'd be
very interested in
it's again like it's very um we don't
know what these materials can do
and we also don't know what they're
really good for so it's kind of like you
know we're all going in that direction
and finding things out so this is like
super exciting if we can talk more
definitely
a hot is is uh asking you know an issue
with
working with thin materials is out of
plane deformation
so they're wondering how have you
constrained or prevented that kind of
motion in your designs
um mostly it's rather simple
um that we're just like you know uh
extruding the
um orthogonal direction that takes care
of the out of plane buckling for
for the most cases so like here um okay
natural black ones right so these are
kind of the ruffles so we optimize like
this
uh in this plane and then you just
extrude them in the
uh other direction until you know that
there's
really not much out of plain buckling
happening so that's mostly how we did it
um also for the for the other types of
metal materials they were just like the
stars were much
smaller but then you know again like it
was a cubic cell but it was it was very
it was sufficient to um you know not
have that
out of plain buckling um plus for the
dual edge
if you have the entire um latch for
example that would of course
buckle out of plane but since it's
integrated into that door
um you know it it's held in those
directions as well so
yeah this is mostly how how we um got
around that but
but yeah i mean uh if you have
this is again something that that one
would uh want to integrate in
in the optimization that you that really
constrain like rather than not caring
about the other dimension that you
really explicitly constrain for it if
it's
something very vulnerable
i guess i have a question um i think uh
because michael
mentioned you were involved in a project
about 3d printing very large structures
and i and talking about i guess like a
whole like racetrack size
thing made out of metamaterials so have
you thought about
like how big you could scale up uh
things that use this and like any
challenges that might arise when you try
and
uh do something like
yeah very good question um uh
both of you um i think it mostly comes
down to
uh this uh uh you know notion
of uh you know how do you fabricate it
like with 3d printing
it would be very hard and you know
wouldn't make sense economically really
uh to to do like a you know to lay out a
uh um
uh race track with uh metal materials
now if you had
uh you know ways to fabricate that in a
more
um you know mass customizable way
um then you can absolutely do that so i
think like you know these structures
from
from sheet materials
are one way that we look into we also um
as i mentioned look
look into um other like you know molding
um a rather generic um um
geometry and like the complex geometry
would be molded and industrially made in
mass
by industry and you can order it on
amazon let's say
and then um and then you know we have an
editor that generates some very simple
geometry that you can customize it to
your own needs at home
so that's kind of like another thing
that we're looking at we're really
investigating
um this web you know this notion of
making them more mass fabricable
because i think that is really one
reason why you don't see
metal materials in real life so far
it could be in our lives if you want it
we've got a question asking what are the
main challenges you think you foresee
that
you need for wide adoption of mechanical
meta materials like
what do we take to get from here to
there
[Music]
yeah thanks for the question i think um
i think it's um
i think it's really again the the the
fabricability and making them in mass
will make a big difference
um and that means that we need to design
new geometries
that are mass producible so
that is what i what i see is the biggest
obstacle right now
um and then and then you know there's
like the more academic side of the
things where you're just like wandering
out of curiosity what else can they do
um but uh you know you can you can
really
create the any type of uh
you know you can you can control bending
behavior of almost anything that you
that
that you want to make from these
materials but if if you have to 3d print
them you won't use them
yeah we've got a question for wondering
about um
overbidding or arriving in undesirable
states of the structures like can you
can you what kind of guarantees can you
provide
that if you're performing actions on
safe configurations you'd never arrive
at an unsafe state
like basically safety issues yeah
very good question um i assume you mean
during usage
or doing like in the kind of design
optimization part of things or well i
think it's sort of the question is tying
together both they're saying
uh worried or i don't know about word
just wondering um
about possible safety issues
in deployment after it's created so if i
if i
pull the lever too far can it you know
can it get into an unsafe state
and what can we do with design time to
make sure that that doesn't happen
yeah right um so i think
for um you know during operation
essentially the same rules apply as to
um all the other
things we already have in our lives um
so you need to test them
and uh you know you need to um like
bridges are made for a certain load and
so you
need to make sure that um that is not
um kind of uh you know exceeded
um and and if would
you know you need to have the tolerances
and need to have the measurements
essentially in place for
uh just about any engineering um
construct um and then um at design time
um i think these are really um the
things that you want to add constraints
so we have that a little bit in that
door ledge didn't talk about it but
there was like
you know geometry that you know was
under the door handle
like that and then so if you push down
the door handle it would stop there so
you couldn't like over extend it and
then tear the whole um
other part down the parts
maybe i can just go back to that
so essentially here this part here
um you know prevents the door latch from
the door handle from uh you know moving
down further
um this whole part here at the top these
cells they are only
designed to kind of extend to allow for
that movement and to attach it to the
top
but they don't really have function like
that they're not necessary for the
um for the mechanism to move the way it
should
they're really there to there are
essentially a safety mechanism if it's a
will
um to attach it to the top um and
uh and make it there for uh more secure
um so these are all the things that you
can do kind of like you know have
tolerances
um you know simulate different uh
behaviors
um and generate geometry that prevents
that behavior from happening
um and then um yeah and other than that
just
testing and knowing what the limits are
so i got one last one this one's from me
um i'm curious yeah we've seen
we've seen a lot in your presentation
about how we can
create interactive tools to aid the
creation of mechanical
devices and i'm wondering if we kind of
invert that a little bit if we say
or at least if if instead of interaction
being the input interaction is the
output you know if we wanted
to add a little bit of
not mechanical but digital to this um
and not
not not in physically instantiated but
if there were going to be
um actual electronics integrated with
these kinds of things
you know i guess what i'm trying to
figure out is where
where's the natural line to draw what
should we be using these meta materials
for
and what is it at the end what is it
ultimately a better idea just that
you think you should be like look just
you know stick a
um stick a simple circuit in there or or
add a
simple a simple screen and you'll get
way farther
yeah absolutely and that is a really
great question
and that's one of the main questions
that i asked myself for every single
projects like why do that in cells
um and i think often um
the so one thing that that ice boils
down to is making it um actually simpler
so we we're designing that geometry such
that we don't have to add
all of these motors that need like you
know lots of circuitry you need to have
like multi
like a lot of addressable cells
essentially but they would already
incorporate some of the um elements now
all of my work was really purely passive
but that is really the extreme case so
what you can also think about
is that you have um you know a larger
material and then you have like
instead of having 100 actuators in there
to
you know drive it the way you want it um
you can optimize some areas to kind of
like do some transformation that you
need
and then and then have like maybe five
actuators in there that
drive it in a meaningful way so um one
example that i
um want to share here is like even
looking at these types of
um cells even more closely we're
interested in
kind of like robotic behavior that can
be embedded in that
in these structured and like really even
unfettered
behavior um such that you can have i
don't know like a robot that
is not so general purpose as a
um you know a robo arm or like you know
heavy machinery
um but uh but um you know it had it can
walk crawl and uh jump and you know
maybe
go in this into a disaster area and take
some
you know stream some video so it can be
very small it can have like
a set of behavior but not like of
movements
but not be like super generic it could
be
um you know it can crawl
in like narrow spaces that like bigger
robots couldn't uh go to so
this is kind of like the realm of things
where i see these type of materials
being
uh useful and even with you know
integrated with more
uh you know electronics and not as
puristic as i um looked at them so far
okay well let's all thank alex for
joining us
uh on a friday evening now in
in in pittsburgh thanks so much thank
you so much
it's uh yeah great to hear the talk and
to see see the kinds of things you've
been you've been up to
we very much look forward to seeing your
uh your contributions
uh grow and and take flight at carnegie
mellon now that you've started there
and uh we hope you have a wonderful
weekend
yeah thanks uh you too and enjoy your
holidays and
um thanks so much for having me
of course see you later bye